[Music]
i made a whole plate of pancakes just
for that stupid [ __ ] bit
it's fine it's fine edge dancer i will
start off with a
brief review for those who aren't
familiar with
our good friend lyft and then i'll
switch to spoiler territory for those of
us who want to get into the real good
stuff that's really uh i think i should
get some syrup
so i was looking on the internet and it
turned out all you
you brandon sanderson fans are quite
divided on a certain character
a character we met in words of radiance
a character called lift for those of you
who don't know what words of radiance is
or what the [ __ ] i'm talking about this
may not be the video for you because
you probably don't want to be reading
edge dancer unless you are
caught up with at least words of
radiance in brandon sanderson's
epic stormlight archive let's face it
the
actual oh i'm afraid to touch the book
now because my hands are sticky in the
book the actual
first 20 like 20 of the book is just
a chapter from words of radiance one of
the interlude chapters
some people were probably annoyed
because
it's like well i just paid you know for
this whole thing
which is it's small it's like 200
something pages and 20
of it is a chapter from a book i've
already read i actually enjoyed this
book a lot but first things first
i want to do a little bit of a an
analysis
of our friend lyft and why i think she's
such an iconic character why i think she
is one of the best characters
in the whole series
a chaotic weird-ass child i can
appreciate that
i was fairly weird in my time if you're
coming into this book you're
already going to know this information
lyft is part of the night's radiant she
doesn't really understand it yet
she has a spren who she calls
a voidbringer and she just keeps calling
him that i think she knows that he's not
a voidbringer but she just likes
likes messing with him she likes giving
him a hard time i don't know how old she
is
in my mind she's like 12 but she could
be older
she loves to be on the road she loves to
run around
we meet her in words of radiance and in
the prologue of this book
she is robbing a castle some some pow
she's robbing a palace
using her powers and her powers which i
think i displayed
quite eloquently in the brief
introduction to this video
she becomes awesome as she puts it she
says
i'm ready to become awesome her power is
basically she eats a lot of
[ __ ] pancakes and then she becomes
like a buttery
fish she becomes slippery so she can
evade people she can slide on the ground
and just go
all slippery that's the extent of her
power
which is admittedly a tiny bit lame but
it's also very cool
when you think about it and when
sanderson uses it to
advance the story she can do a lot with
that slipperiness and
steal and rob and get out of sticky
situations pun
intended i understand why people think
she's annoying because
she is a simple soul she likes to
consume food because that gives her her
power so she goes to the city
because she wants to get some pancakes
which even though a person who's trying
to kill her
is in this city she goes there because
she wants to try these
pancakes that this city is famous for i
guess what is so great about lyft's
character i think and i haven't
finished oathbringer yet i'm working on
it sanderson hasn't given her the whole
flashback treatment
in way of kings he gave kaladin the
flashback treatment in words of radiance
did the same with shalon and an
oathbringer he was doing it with dalinar
i think there are good things with the
flashback stuff we learn
a lot about the characters but also
there is
sometimes a too much information and
having a bit of mystery is nice
lyft has kind of a mysterious past so
it's at this point i'm just going to go
into
spoiler territory it's implied that
lyft's past is
really difficult and rough and that
she's really pushing back
a lot of her emotions i think she has
some kind of i think she lost her mom
at an early age i believe she tried to
use the old magic
to stay young forever even though it's
not necessarily working because she
is getting taller so this kind of
background is peppered throughout the
story
very lightly and that may be why people
don't really like lyft that much
she seems like a very one note character
in a lot of ways
she just don't give a [ __ ] about nothing
and that changes
unlike in words of radiance she now has
a full story in in order to
develop her character i thought that it
was done very well
she is a character like dalinar like
caledon
like shalon that have these deep
difficult pasts
and they're using different ways to cope
with them paladin wants to
save everybody shalon creates lies
for herself and for others in order to
deal with her past
lyft she constantly is in motion and
there are some
really you know poignant moments in the
story where lyft
understands this and says to herself you
know not moving is death
because then people can't attach
themselves to you because then people
can't expect anything from you she just
wants to be on the road and keep moving
and
what's great about the story is that her
becoming a
knight's radiant means that she is going
to have to grow beyond that
i'm so glad i made this many pancakes
for those of you interested in what i
thought about the
actual novella the actual book i mean
lyft is
perfect i mean i have nothing really to
say that's that's wrong with lyft
there's kind of a wish fulfillment with
a lot of people just being like a
slippery goofball
eating pancakes all day that sounds
pretty nice however the book has
some issues i think some of that can
just be attributed to
lyft being a young person i thought the
prose was a bit
choppy i was wondering if it was just
sanderson if i was i was just reading
other stuff with
fancier prose and i was just kind of
like huh this doesn't this is a bit
choppy
but then i started reading reading
oathbringer and i was like whoa compared
to edge dancer both bringers like really
gorgeous pros and i was like not really
what sanderson's known for but i was
really impressed with
oathbringer's writing style and i think
that's because edge dancer was written
it's from lyft's perspective the whole
book except for one chapter she's a kid
she has kind of a childlike perspective
of the world
i thought the city yazir i kind of
forget what it's called but
the city that she goes to i thought was
kind of not
very i guess it was memorable but i
didn't find it that interesting
it's sort of like the chasms except as a
city and there's like buildings within
all the chasms at least that was the
impression i got of the city
i wasn't crazy about it also lyft's
motivation
is admittedly weak throughout most of
the book she goes to the city
for kind of vague reasons she wants
pancakes
there's a guy hunting her there she ends
up wanting to
save the person that i think his name
was darkness
the person trying to kill her she's
trying to save his next victim so that
involves going to a library and doing
research which sanderson
makes it funny in goofy but it's still
a bit dull in some ways it really didn't
get super interesting until like the
two-thirds mark where she meets that
[ __ ]
crab guy what the [ __ ] the crab
i don't understand i was so confused he
seems like some kind of ancient
god or terrifying creature but this old
man that she meets
by the orphanage turns out to be some
kind of like mythic
creature who like controls crabs and his
body is made of crabs what the hell
that was like a weird body horror like
scene in this book is like genuinely
frightening and then
the person who i believe is like an
honor
radiant who's been hunting her she ends
up convincing him to be good
because the everstorm everstorm comes in
and he sees all the voidbringers and
he's trying to avoid
that situation but he just can't help it
now and so he kind of gets off lifts
back
and it's a really good ending things are
really wrapped
up and made me really want to read
oathbringer which is
how it should be i will say reading this
book was a bit of a chore
because you open up oathbringer and you
have this massive book in your hands you
open it up and you
and you read i like to read the
acknowledgements a little bit and it
says
you know you may want to read a novella
that in between words of radiance and no
spring
i have to read more just to read
okay all right so i kind of went into it
as
this is feels like kind of a chore i
came out of it as you know it was a
positive experience
essential i don't really think so except
for
lyft you know just being hilarious and
having some character development
fantastic all around i really enjoyed it
i really did oh
my notes just says page 189 say it lyft
said
your pancake fullness i just love lyft
say it lyft has all this power all of a
sudden and this ardent is going your
pancake fullness
iconic there were moments in this that
made me really smile
i enjoyed it well i might just stay here
and eat the rest of this on camera
so what did you all think of edge dancer
have you read it right do you want to
read it what do you think of lyft
annoying cringe or
[ __ ] amazing which is okay if you're
new to this channel
like and subscribe it helps a lot i
really have nothing else to say
um so bye